grab a refreshing tab Cola and a
delicious prison burger because we have
the 100th episode of American Horror
Story but before we get into our
detailed breakdown if you haven't
checked out Castle Rock I highly
recommend it and yes I do breakdowns for
it hashtag shameless self plug we're in
1985 approximately a year after the
events of camp redwoods second massacre
at the beautiful Hollywood premier motel
you know it's a high-end establishment
with the amount of prostitutes in the
parking lot last episode we left off
with Ricky and jingles heading off to
Los Angeles to start a beautiful life
together terrorizing this city of angels
but a year in things aren't going so
well for our friend jingles we'll get
into that in a bit a German woman on
vacation with her husband Horst and her
two children of the corn look-alikes
goes over to Ricky's room to tell him to
turn it down after all they have a busy
day at Disneyland tomorrow also I love
these tiny details like the husband
wearing a Hollywood souvenir shirt so
you know they're from out of town
Ricky opens his smoke-filled room eyeing
the German woman sexually in the
background you can hear Billy Idol's
flesh for fantasy and we know how much
Ricky loves Billy he grabs the woman but
jingles warns him to let her go and what
is with that facial air jingles I mean
come on
jingles and Ricky have been here for a
year and living with Ricky has gotten on
jingles nerves he doesn't like the music
and Ricky lives like an animal
oh and they're constantly killing in
fact jingle says he's killed 11 and
constantly haunted by the faces of his
victims he wants out but Ricky reminds
him it's not your decision to make
Satan gave you life if you remember at
the end of last episode jingles was
killed by Xavier and later given a
second chance at life through the
resurrected Ricky he made a deal with
the devil and although we never hear
what this actual deal is it's safe to
assume it was life in exchange for
eternal service to the Dark Lord service
which means killing and if jingles
breaks this deal there will be hell to
pay
literally paranoid by Black Sabbath
plays as we see a short montage of
jingles watching disapprovingly as ricky
kills at a nearby convenience store
Ricky
in for a beer and jingles changes the
song to REO speedwagon's can't fight
this feeling which has the lyric I've
forgotten what I started fighting for
our poor jingles feels trapped he's
forgotten what he's fighting for
while looking at the paper he sees that
Ricci has been identified and is wanted
for murder
totally off topic but there's also an
article talking about hurricane Elena
which was a real hurricane that pummeled
Florida around the same time jingles
buys a copy of the paper and gives it to
a woman who notices Riki in the store
soon a crowd of locals surround Riki
calling him Elma Truong and if the
high-school Spanish I mean Google
Translate is right that means the bully
he's chased down by the group and beaten
to a pulp as our tab drinking jingles
drives off into the distance
and we're back at Camp redwood in the
year 1989 five years after the events of
Episode five we meet Dustin the bird
watcher who stumbled across the camp in
search for waterfowl he passes one of
the cabins which has since been
abandoned and has graffiti exclaiming
Brooke wants your blood and not to howl
Brooke was framed by Margaret for the
1984 massacre home sweet home by motley
crew plays when we see Montana
sunbathing at the dock we saw her last
episode become one of the ghosts of
redwood unable to leave the grounds but
it seems as though she's made herself at
home wanting to open our precious
birdwatchers fanny pack I'm also curious
if he takes a photo over will she be
visible in it anyway she tries to seduce
him and he tells her he has a girlfriend
we'll get to her in a bit but he
succumbs to her charms and is brutally
murdered by her
we then see midge and the other two
counselors from the original massacre
commenting how unsophisticated Montana
is Xavier calls them old-timers and
proceeds to make out with Montana
remember in episode 1 we learned that
they used to date so it looks like
they've rekindled things the
introduction of the original counselors
here is interesting because it may throw
a wrench in the idea that the only
people who come back from the dead here
are those that need to be redeemed and
Margaret Booth is now on lifestyles of
the rich and famous which was a real
show in the 80s and 90s which featured
the extravagant lifestyles of wealthy
entertainers athletes and business
moguls my god that hair she's used her
money from her dead husband the same one
we heard about briefly in Episode one to
buy properties with a dark history and
turn them into attractions properties
like serial killer John Wayne Gacy z--
house the Briarcliff Manor which was the
main focus of season two's Asylum
Winchester Mystery House which was the
inspiration for the film Winchester with
Helen Mirren and spawns movie Ranch
where Charles Manson plotted his murders
and in an absolutely shocking twist
trevor is still alive and married to
Margaret the same woman who stabbed him
in Episode four and cut off his ear also
look at that sweet cell phone this
relationship isn't what it's cracked up
to be
Trevor's a coke and alcohol addict and
Margaret has given up on God through a
flashback we learned that trevor is in
it for the money rather than accuse
Margaret for the murders
lose in court he might as well get
something out of it and use Margaret as
his sugar mama but Margaret only agrees
if he becomes her husband since you
can't make your spouse testify against
you but now Trevor feels trapped
just like jingles when Margaret's
assistant Courtney comes in this guy
just plays the most ridiculous
characters he was in season three's
coven or you might remember him as the
eccentric medium cricket in season six
is Roanoke
he tells them that Brook has just lost
her appeal and is set to be executed
going down what I believe to be death
row Brooke is confronted by Rickey who
has since been captured Xavier in
Montana go through Dustin's campsite
when Trey strolls in piss that they've
killed another innocent person none of
them know why they're stuck there and
the old-timers seemed to be just as
pissed as ray at the total disregard
Xavier in Montana have for other
people's lives they uncover a paper
telling them a Brooks soon-to-be
execution when Dustin's girlfriend
arrives and Xavier makes quick work of
her Brooke is haunted by Ricky and the
thoughts of her impending death with the
words your final home written in her
cell Ricky has somehow astral projected
with the powers of Satan and makes
Brooke a deal his master believes she
has potential and asked her to join them
to which she politely declines we get
another shot of Ricky with those black
eyes which we also saw possess Michael
Langdon last season
Margaret receives a report from Courtney
that things are going well at their
Lizzie Borden property the woman who was
suspected of killing her father and
stepmother with an axe in 1892 Courtney
suggests they sell the business while
their business is hot but Margaret's
greed is too much which is a likely
indicator that Margaret will die the
season and lose everything
Trevor shows them a newspaper damn
there's a lot of newspapers in this
episode that reports on the two found
dead at Camp redwood and since they
still own the property they could be
held liable but Margaret sees
opportunity in this we catch up to
jingles who has started a new life in
Alaska with a woman named Lorraine this
actress also played Hayden McClaine
sister in season One's murder house
jingles apparently saved this woman's
life she used to be a prostitute so it's
possible that they met at the Hollywood
premiere they both now live a happy new
life with jingles working at Video Shack
which is a throwback to video rental
stores like Blockbuster here
see his new alias Donald and some fun
fake movie posters in the back Donald
might be up for a new position at the
opening of a new video Shack in Juneau
as Brett says lots of opportunities in
VHS Margaret comes up with the brilliant
idea to go back to camp redwood with a
food and music festival people can
actually stay in the cabins where the
massacre happened what could go wrong we
also see Chet interacting with Montana
here pretty much confirming that he did
indeed die via drowning by Margaret and
he wants his revenge jingles watches the
announcement of the festival telling
Lorraine he's over it he has a new life
and he's free
but is he meanwhile back in jail Riki is
visited by an admirer simply known as
red she tells him of camp redwoods Music
Festival and we learn of Ricky's desire
to be remembered this was hinted at in
previous episodes when he admired
jingles for being a legend he wants to
be one - Brooke enjoys her last meal of
Snapple and I've no idea what that is
when Ricky offers her one last chance a
last chance she declines Ricky has made
a pentagram to communicate with his
master just like he did in Episode four
and like Michael Langdon did in season
eight he wants his master to give him
another shot at immortality and in
return will give him a torrent of fresh
souls Brooke pleads her innocence
spitting at Margaret behind the glass
she's locked in and given lethal
injection dying two minutes later in
fact Margaret and Trevor are bored of
the whole process wishing that they
would bring back something more exciting
like the guillotine at the same time
Ricky as some of the power of his master
which takes control of the guard who
then sets him free
Donald is chastised by a customer giving
them rom-coms instead of a horror which
is probably gonna affect that big
promotion he's supposed to get when he
arrives home he finds Lorraine brutally
murdered luckily his little boy Bobby is
still alive with his sign written in
blood saying Satan will have his
vengeance the back of it has a picture
of the camp redwood festival leading us
to believe it was Ricky who had the same
flyer with him in his cell I also liked
the use of the word SCORM a food and
luxury tents which were the same words
used to describe the disastrous fire
festival will you
suck I also think it's a bit weird if it
was Ricky who left that note that he
went all the way to Alaska then back to
California that's a really long trip
jingles knew he would one day pay for
not keeping his deal with the devil and
decides to end everything once and for
all by going back to camp redwood to
finish Ricky once and for all
he leaves his child with Lauren's sister
saying his goodbyes as if he's never
going to come back he puts on his iconic
mr. jingles raincoat and makes sure to
bring his keys with him and in our final
scene Brooke is resuscitated by none
other than Rita it's never really
explained how Rita was able to bring her
back considering if Brooke was
pronounced dead her heart would have
stopped
so whatever Rita injected into her veins
must have been pretty powerful the last
time we saw Rita she asked jingles to
kill her for what she had unleashed on
the camp Rita is looking for redemption
and from her conversation with jingles
nose Brooke is innocent and that
Margaret is the real killer with Brooke
wanting Margaret to pay and read in
search of redemption the two will likely
team up and head back to camp redwood
with our characters all making their way
back to camp it looks like the last few
episodes will center around the final
camp redwood massacre I'm just hoping
it's not as disastrous as fire festival
thanks for watching everyone please make
sure to give the video a like and
comment below with your theories and
thoughts you can also reach me on
twitter at think story' whitey until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much